et jean marc collienne et laurent fillon
ont passé un jour avec jay soit si le
reportage nous sommes dans l'atelier de
jesse est ici sa tanière au 14e
kilomètre au tampon ça fait 25 ans que
jesse fait des gourous et devinez ce
qu'il est en train de faire en ce moment
dans le jardin et vous où il est simple
tu as une tête qui valent ses deux bras
mon petit corps un taux de 10 ça ne
m'est pas si simple ça ce n'est pas si
simple c'est vrai que en fait la
simplicité c'est pas bien de plus précis
d'épuration graphique ça demande une
certaine une certaine critique
médiatique
[Musique]
le présenter à quelqu'un qui ne connaît
pas le bon outil présenté comme en irak
c'est un petit bonhomme facétieux
moqueur wenger l'espiègle engagé dès
fois romantiques tout moi quoi aucun
défaut est-ce qu'il a créé donc c'est
sûr ce sens au sens premier du terme et
l'écrire puisqu'il est né à la réunion
[Musique]
mais pas que
il était rien il est un peu tout le
monde donc j'ai pas envie de
[Musique]
le poser sur une zone géographique des
combats de clocher sa main ça me saoule
impôts tout en le rendant plus universel
possible dans son atelier j'ai esprits
par les expositions auxquelles il est
invité un peu partout dans le monde
il peint des toiles qui se vendent
aujourd'hui à plusieurs centaines ou
plusieurs milliers d'euros
mais régulièrement il s'en va encore ces
bombes sous le bras pour graffer
librement dans la rue où ce matin sous
un pont à la ravine blanche à saint
pierre
il a toujours voulu garder cette
activité là le côté un peu pirates
j'adore ce qui me fait vivre est d'abord
illégal c'est la base de mon travail
c'est de la joie
[Musique]
là ça peut encore arriver malgré sa
notoriété que la police arrive et te
demandent d'arrêter complètement à tout
moment elle a produit serait arrivé
monsieur qu'est ce que vous faites vous
avez l'autorisation depuis mes débuts
dans la peinture
jamais content il est resté comme une
dégradation ce que je faisais donc
toujours resté toujours essayé de
d'argumenter et de d'expliquer ma
démarche leur montrer que c'est pas une
démarche
vandal mais au contraire ces dernières
il ya démarche artistique
d'un côté la mer
descendra aussi coty en photo tout
dessus maintenant les gens font plus des
photos avec moi qu'il appelle la police
avant ils n'étaient pas contents de me
voir maintenant ils sont contents et ils
sont fiers d'avoir été le premier à être
sur les lieux du crime
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tu es très connu et pourtant
tu veux rester anonyme oui ça peut
paraître paradoxal
l'idée c'est pas de focaliser sur ma
personne c'est avec le regard déjà vaste
le plus neutre possible
et puis c'est aussi une manière de
préserver moi mon rôle intimité ma vie
privée
servisair est comme le bush d'état
[Musique]
bien que le graffeur un message oui on
peut dire ça mais pas que bon équilibre
entre ces amusants et voilà c'est ça le
moment les trucs qui me révolte et du
coup je vais aller dire une connerie
dessus globalement il est quand même
très écolo tambours
oui oui oui il est trop occupé de part
son avenir malgré tout
[Musique]
au fil des ans les blues ou sont devenus
une affaire qui roule
il ya même aujourd'hui à saint pierre
une usine à glee
[Musique]
lusine à gulu est une boutique mais elle
abrite aussi depuis peu une galerie
d'art qui accueille d'autres artistes
adeptes du street art au fil des ans
gc s'est installé il s'est
professionnalisé mais ne risque-t-il pas
d'y perdre un peu le côté artisanal
[Musique]
e
je sais pas je ne sais pas j'essaye en
tout cas de de faire un équilibre entre
mon travail de rue et ce travail un peu
plus commercial en tout cas si si ça
devient que ça venait de mettre des
claques ce parce que ce ne sera plus le
sort a perdu son sens premier
aujourd'hui une toile de jesse ça peut
valoir plusieurs milliers d'euros
tu dis bien tant d'arts aujourd'hui ça
serait mentir que de dire que je vis mal
de mon art bien sûr que oui ça fait
quelques années que j'ai envie j'ai
envie bien après comme toute chose comme
tout artiste ça peut prendre ça peut
s'arrêter aussi du jour au lendemain
après c'est aussi un travail qui est qui
est un vrai travail mais j'en pense ils
ont une image de l'artiste avec le joint
dans la bouche quand il se réveille à
midi mais c'est pas ça du tout quoi
annoncer des heures et des heures de
boulot pour en arriver là
j'essaye de faire mon truc
professionnellement et c'est ce qui me
permet je pense d'eux
de durer aussi dans le temps la journée
s'achève à l'aéroport roland garros
il a été chargé de réaliser une fresque
pour la nouvelle salle d'embarquement
pour lui la nuit va être très longue on
va découvrir tout de suite il est déjà
au travail
[Musique]
dès aujourd'hui sa des gousses donné ton
métier faire des besoins oui entre
autres a globalement créé avec un moment
qui a accepté très décousu sur commande
c'est vrai c'est vrai que la randonnée
j'ai un peu passé le pas s'est imposé
après mme de conscience ouais bien sûr
bien sûr parce que venant du graffiti
initialement on fait pas de business
avec le graffiti et puis les mentalités
ont évolué depuis les années 2000 et
beaucoup d'artistes maintenant vivre de
leur peinture c'est moi c'est ma passion
j'ai envie de faire ça tous les jours
j'ai de la chance de vivre de ma passion
ça serait bête de s'en priver maintenant
[Musique]